I can't wait to see all my friends at my
annual fourth of July barbecue it's
always amazing gonna be there won't you
Andy I'm not I'm not gonna go to your
barbecue why not wait weren't you gonna
go to my barbecue because I went last
year what's that supposed to mean I did
not have a good time last year baby what
are you talking about I threw a great
party last year an amazing party I
remember it perfectly don't want this
Kobe beef to go to waste
hey Conan what a great pool party we
don't get tired of looking at that hot
body happy fourth of July everybody
happy fourth of July okay Andy I think
you've had a little too much to drink
Joel you tell me I'm head
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm telling you Andy it was a great
party you're the one who ruined it that
is not what happened there were no women
in bikinis there were women in bikinis
I'm pretty sure there were anyway no and
you were the one who had too much to
drink that's how I remember it
[Applause]
[Music]
hey you guys want some mustard on your
wiener sure hey that's funny and I know
funny hey Conan what a great pool party
we don't get tired of looking at that
hot body
thanks guys yeah man this sucks I'm
going home you're not gonna go anywhere
this is a terrible party you said they
were gonna be fireworks oh you want to
see fire Oh get you some fireworks
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
and has my time and out the whole time
anyway you should try and come to the
party it's gonna be fine I will now that
potato salad up my nose yeah I don't
want to hear about it